what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch the official
trailer or trailer two or whatever the heck
you were supposed to be called for Avatar
the way of what her John how are you I'm I'm
very curious and excited I am very curious
too you didn't ask me but yeah all right sir
I'm doing I'm very good I'm very curious excited
to see this guys please go ahead leave a like
that'd be extremely appreciated also do want
to give a mention that today's video is sponsored
by wondery excited to be working with them
again because we actually use their services
yeah we got more on them after the after we
do the trailer reaction for Avatar but please
do give it a listen and supporting them supports
the channel and it really does because uh
because it does it's just a fact let's watch
this trailer
[Music]
God damn
oh
wow little one dad I know you think I'm crazy
[Music] but I feel her
[Music] I hear her heartbeat [Music] oh wow
so close the luminescence
what does her heartbeat sound like
wow oh my goodness
mighty [Music]
damn
that was unexpected we cannot let you bring
your War here cast that's all they see I see
you I see you
wave water connects all things that's the
title of the move hey before your birth and
after your death the circle of life oh my
God those underwater fights are gonna be nuts
did you with me and I need you to be strong
wow jeez foreign
[Music]
that looks amazing that looks absolutely gorgeous
and stunning and I know James Horner is no
longer with us but man that music who's taking
over oh I forget the guy's name but it's one
of his assistants one of the guys who worked
closely with him it's doing an amazing job
so far and it feels like a dream come true
and you know I kept hearing about how they
developed that you know technology just so
they could do the underwater sequences I didn't
expect fight scenes underneath that for some
reason my mind didn't go there but when you
are seeing the Machinery like wow this looks
crazy a lot of this looks straight up like
an anime at times yeah like brought to life
in the most complementary ways that the connection
to life connection to life and the elements
in general the amount of you know culture
and and sort of tribal beauty that the first
movie had is just like all over this but like
times 10 because it's that much more immersive
I feel like that we have something perhaps
pretty special on our hands that could be
very powerful because this looks very gut
wrenching as well harrowing like there are
parts of it that felt so much darker than
I expected it to be I feel like this will
be like 10 times more emotional than the first
one the first one was pretty emotional for
people I really liked the first one a lot
I wouldn't say I'm like super emotional when
I watch it this feels like it could go into
some pretty dark territory dark Waters it
looks like it goes some pretty dark territory
that I'm personally pretty excited for there's
such a great sense of wonder to it all and
uh speaking of wonder thanks to wondery for
working with us again and sponsoring this
video and yet again for introducing us to
another fantastic podcast one that I didn't
expect to be saying is a fantastic podcast
because it's a show that I was like kind of
up and down about there were some episodes
that we really didn't like and there were
some episodes that we really liked and a couple
that we actually quite loved it was such an
up and down Journey but this podcast from
the first episode alone made me go wow I already
appreciate this show that much more and that
is the official the Lord of the Rings the
rings of power podcast first thing they took
me about this podcast is that it's host by
Felicia Day many of you guys might know she's
like the most Ultimate Fantasy nerds out there
I personally didn't know about her until she
was introduced in Supernatural where I thought
she was great in it on this podcast It Go
episode by episode through the whole season
and they interview Talon from in front of
the camera to behind the scenes for example
the first episode is with I don't know you've
probably got very much Clark I believe the
actress who plays Galadriel she always pronounces
the correct two on the podcast yes while listening
to it I was like wow you know what I I liked
this first episode that much more ready and
I like Galadriel that much more ready because
I started to understand a lot more of the
insight and the approach due to the fact that
Felicia Day from both just being a fantasy
nerd but also being an actress as well just
gets the best questions in there yeah I really
loved it you're talking to me about the finale
recently yeah they also had JD Payne and Patrick
McKay who are the show Runners on to break
down the finale and then they talk about other
episodes as well across the series it's fascinating
to know because there's been so much made
out of what they have access to and what they
have to work with you know hearing what their
reasoning was for why they guided the season
the way they did and just the human elements
of being there day to day and you know making
this insurmountably big production is fascinating
stuff really I would say that if you enjoyed
the rings of power you're more than likely
going to love this podcast so please give
it a shot even if you were kind of just like
sort of where we were in the middle if you
were like us to me it made the viewing experience
of the Rings of power that much more rewarding
so you know as they say here to go into the
canals of Newman
watch the rings of power on Prime video and
listen to all eight episodes of the official
the Lord of the Rings the rings of power podcast
for free on Amazon music you could download
the Amazon music app now I did that so join
me on that Journey Don't forget to check out
the Wonder app or subscribe to wondery plus
and apple podcasts for more they're becoming
like the go-to center for my podcast so thank
you wondering for working with a loyal customer
I mean I feel like the word epic is used tossed
around so like casually it's like no other
word that really comes to mind for me when
I see this trailer is that it does feel epic
it feels cinematically sweeping like a true
spectacle of sorts thinking about you know
thematically what they might be dealing with
and story wise seems to deal so much with
Legacy and generations you know saying like
the way of water and and how it tells a story
of before your birth and after your death
spending this much time and then in this trailer
you know it starts off where you see natiri
she's pregnant and then you're watching soon
like you're seeing the children and you're
seeing parts of the home being destroyed and
devastated you've seen them having to start
a new you know there's so many different qualities
that you're seeing here of things ending things
beginning things ending things beginning to
have it be called the way of water or what
they're talking about what the water can represent
you're seeing that just with the generational
Lifestyles or know what the child's name is
but the child at the beginning of this trailer
I imagine that because it was in in the first
movie it was
thinking how you pronounce it that's kind
of the sense of what I get she's talking about
feeling her heartbeat and such so you're seeing
in the first movie again a generational handoff
in a way not saying like this movie's like
maybe it is I don't know but in terms of legacy
and life and death for the new life to be
experiencing this connection the way how their
father had to deal with it within the first
film and then getting messages about what
to do and then feeling mighty they've inherited
this war with the RDA you know as opposed
to the navi before them their children are
born into this war and to be talking about
feeling mighty it's like they have to be born
with a certain sense of strength they're already
born with strength and now I can imagine just
how much more Mighty that strength ought to
be yeah absolutely it feels like everything
is at stake and I think it's really smart
to lead with just the tone and the lifestyle
the richness of the world more so I mean like
you get a sense for the plot and certainly
in this trailer you get a sense for What conflict
is arising and perhaps returning from the
past but I appreciate that even still there's
a good amount more focus on just what this
movie is going to feel like as an experience
rather than like oh what's the plot and everything
like that because we know certain people they've
said or returning who perished last time and
even home tree was destroyed and now here
to see it you know to see part of it being
that we're sort of reconnecting to that energy
and maybe perhaps finding a new you know home
tree for them to you know Center their entire
tribe and culture around you know after the
events of the first movie it's been so long
after I I feel like it makes this feeling
of return and this feeling of rediscovery
of something truly special feel palpable and
that's lovely because it takes into account
sort of the real life circumstances and all
the time that it's taken to get here but it
puts it out there in a way that's really beautiful
and that hones in on what I liked most about
the original movie which is again just the
realization and the the real attention to
detail and to just the life that is this world
and yeah all these talk about heartbeats and
Cycles going you know I thought that was really
beautifully represented by this trailer and
oftentimes you know trailers are meant to
do a certain thing give you the Flash and
the sizzle and sell you a movie but this just
really felt like the spirit of what I loved
most about the first Avatar and what I hope
that they can make even more beautiful and
affecting here basically all right well that
was beautiful that was absolutely gorgeous
thank you guys for being here and I thank
you to wondery for sponsoring this video and
yeah we will uh we'll catch you all soon
foreign